we'll pretend we're segwaying from the
florida climate change stuff into the
dating stuff with this story
from 2017 having children is one of the
most destructive things you can do to
the environment
say researchers one fewer child per
family can save
average of 58.6 tons of co2 equivalent
emissions per year
so you've got stories like this and then
you've got
um i think people like aoc you know
kaiser cortez said i'm worried about
having kids because of the environment
you've got a lot of stories popping up
where people saying they're not going to
have kids for political reasons
and so yeah yeah no joke man you look
shocked by this yeah this is something
we talk about quite a bit bill gets to
depopulation i i think depopulation
isn't the right word
no population management they want to
slow the growth of population
or stop it to a great degree or control
it right and so
it starts to get into scary
conversations about eugenics you know
choosing who gets to have kids stuff but
i don't know
what they're doing in that regard other
than you've got articles popping up this
one says researchers from lund
university
found having one fewer child could save
you know 58.6 tons
eating meat driving a car and traveling
by airplane made up the list of the most
polluting things that
people can do on the planet but having
children was top
according to new study so you know i
guess in terms of
where we're headed people don't have
kids people do have their lowest birth
rates
yeah yeah west in general how old are
you guys i'm 31
31 i'm 28. you guys are you guys married
with kids no hell no come on bro
yeah no but think about like uh i don't
know about your parents generation like
how old you
my parents were in their late 20s when
they had multiple kids yeah same
my mom my mom my husband like 40 years
old yeah that explains a lot
yeah yeah am i stuttering
now but my grandparents man like they
were together for like 70 years man like
back then it was more like you know you
find somebody you know you work to the
problems and you figure it out
now it is kind of like hey if you're not
benefiting me
like what's the point here so regarding
kids it's kind of like okay
what's going to have kids with somebody
that you don't really trust so you know
that goes into trust
you know dating relationships so i just
say having kids is a big
deal because now it's two people
together for a lifetime
and most people they want to be for a
reason or season but not for the whole
time
so what's the point of having kids
continue the legacy
i think it's more eagle and i think it's
more eagle bro honestly yeah well
eagle i mean we're we're designed to
procreate man yeah
yeah but like okay if you're living life
living a good life
yeah why do you want kids well it's easy
for us to say that now but when you get
older you're gonna want kids bro
you know i don't know just fortunately
for us we can like push the clock back
longer
yeah as men you know what i'm saying as
a guy like you can you know you can keep
doing it until the day you die but like
you know for women they gotta find that
amount of time because i hear it i want
a
little mini me i'm like heck yeah why do
you want a mini me
is it for your own personal gainer
because you actually want a kid to enjoy
life
that's some questioning like okay is it
about you or your ego or is it about the
kid itself yeah
everyone that has kids says it's the
best thing they've ever done so i i i
believe the hype
but i'm not going to do it until like
i'm completely ready because in today's
day and age you know
you got to be very cautious about doing
it but that's why i think you know so
many people are putting children on the
back burner to
pursue a career making money but were
were our parents ready
that's a good question they were not
you're right they were not yeah my mom's
had kids my mom was on vacation in
barbados when she had me
i was a mistake ah hi mom
yeah but isn't everybody like that's why
it's always funny when you watch on
uh tv shows and they say like a kid was
an accident or whatever i'm like come on
dude like most kids are accidents
yeah like nobody was like all right it's
7 p.m on the third
uh it's time to have a baby some people
do it yeah some people are like i want
my kid to be born on christmas
yeah all right you know we time it
perfectly that's the worst day to be
born to
my friends who are birthdays on
christmas they gonna get any pr they got
congratulations who's your president
have a nice day yeah everybody else got
presents exactly
right tim you're never really ready for
kids because like you might prepare for
it
but it'll happen when it's time who
knows so what's what's
what's the end result of this i mean
we're talking about inflation we're
going to have
if if we don't have more people this
this weird
you like are you guys familiar with the
economic system and the federal reserve
and all that stuff yeah yeah
it's not going to sustain itself of
course it's not more people yeah so then
what it just
china's going to take over
just put it bluntly i guess it was it
was a good run while it lasted
they got 1.4 billion people or whatever
so no but i
i honestly believe man at some point in
time we're gonna have a massive shift
where it's gonna be under one control
which is like the government the food
you know the money and it's kind of like
okay now that we control
you know what's needed in life like you
have to do what i say and
the majority of people are going to kind
of follow a trend and if you don't
follow the trend you're going to be
exercised from
like you know the whole society you know
the current system
so i'm thinking you know what china
think about their current setup
they hardly have any kids it's all
business and structure technology how to
how to expand how to build
an empire versus now america's kind of
like you know
well they want people to have kids now
though in china yeah yeah they got rid
of that rule one one kid per
family it used to be a male but now the
problem is that they've almost
overcorrected the point where like
there's no
women anymore like there's too many too
many men too many bachelors they buy
north korean slaves
oh is that what they're doing yeah yeah
we actually had a woman from north korea
on the show and she was saying like
that's what they do
because there's no women so they just
buy them from north korea oh i didn't
know that
yeah man the world's a dirty place you
know there's like nasty stuff going on
but my question china's like we're gonna
win at any cost
we don't care do you actually have kids
in this current climate right now do you
really want to have kids no yeah but
come on man people had kids during world
war ii people had kids during vietnam
you know pete like the world was messed
up in a lot of ways people still had
kids
i think we're being inundated with
propaganda like this where they're like
you can't have kids the environment you
know
it's really really bad and it's like i
mean that's that's that's true i suppose
like humans
fart and poop and eat and stuff like
that
but people have kids i wouldn't say the
natural environment is the problem like
you know with you know obviously
pollution that plays into it but i think
it's more like
raising a kid in today's day and age and
this contemporary marketplace like ah
like it's it's gonna be tough man like
yeah like i mean family you if
the family unit is not as strong as it
used to be you know nowadays you know
you got
single moms all over the place uh you
know there's a whole bunch of things
which we get to cover later but yeah
i mean it's just it would be tough to
raise children now i know what
what's the future going to look like if
we're not having kids i mean like we're
not
trying to take an overman
i mean if we don't have kids anymore and
we're kind of like you know just
you know doing our thing it is selfish
at the same time but i understand
why people do it my thing is you don't
have kids though it's kind of like
we're gonna be stuck in a certain like
mindset and um you know i would say
hysteria because now we're not bringing
up new ideas and new people
to think about certain things so we're
stuck in a certain like you know box of
okay it's all we think
if you don't agree with it yeah you just
you need to
propagate the next generation you know
right now the birth rates are the lowest
they've ever been you know there's a
bunch of reasons for that you know you
can
feminism you know the cost of living is
went up inflation all these other things
but
you know uh people are millennials now
they're less likely to buy a home you
know they'd rather rent so there's a
bunch of things
you know why i don't believe that rather
rent thing though
no no that's that's absurd like why
would you rather rent
i so you know they can't buy that that's
probably especially with blackrock yeah
yeah
literally like our generation they want
to be entrepreneurs and invest but they
can't they're working at starbucks
they're working as
how are you gonna invest without money
so it's kind of tough i will
i mean but here's the thing man like i'm
i'm like thinking like guys my age group
like
very few of my friends actually own a
home they rent
that's true like like that's what i'm
saying like like uh guys like
an our age group like that i guess would
be considered millennials yeah they're
less likely to buy a home
you know but yeah i agree that yeah
credit is a part of it and then also
they're pushing back because i've always
said it
like there's really no need to buy a
home unless you're to have kids kids
because then you're tied down to that
area and the only reason you would want
to be tied down to a geographic
area is for a good school exactly so i
wouldn't
you know if you're a single guy or
you're even if you're in a relationship
with a woman you know together
a monogamous relationship like unless
you're going to have kids i wouldn't buy
a home because i think it's like
not a it's kind of throwing money at you
you lose your leverage to be able to
maneuver around and do what you want to
do because
now you're confined to one geographic
area on a house that's not true
no just go to a rental management
company and then
you buy let's say you buy a house and
you okay and you live there for one year
like you're like you're gonna do a lease
then you decide you don't want to live
here anymore i want to deal with this
there's probably hundreds or thousands
of rental management companies and you
just oh yeah if you rent it out and you
do that that's good but you don't have
to think about it
yeah but mostly literally they're gonna
keep the house that's what i'm saying
like a lot of people but you still own
it
so so what happens is you buy a house
you own it
you're paying less per month to live
there and then when you decide to leave
and go somewhere else
you call a rental management company you
sign a paper you walk away and you don't
think twice
you don't even you don't even think
about the house anymore it's yours and
then all of a sudden every few months
some money appears in your bank account
yeah if it's if it's like for that where
you're going to rent it back out that's
great but a lot of people
you know they're not i would say they're
going to buy the house and like live in
it but like i have a house you know
yeah like like the american dream you
know the white picket fence at home in a
good school district
i can send my kids to school you know
that's why i why a lot of people buy
a home in a nice area from eagle to as
well they're like oh this is my house
this is where i have things
this is where i have my parties so when
they leave it's like okay i'm leaving
everything behind but i get what you're
saying you can't do that as an option
yeah but majority people that i've seen
in the real estate community
that buy a house and live in italy
i don't think there's good schools
anymore though to be honest that
might be an issue too i would say we're
getting there we're like this with this
pretty soon you're going to just have to
send your kids to a private school or
home school we're going to get there to
that point very soon oh we're there now
dude yeah
we had we had this uh uh azra nomani on
the other day and she's working with a a
bunch of parents
targeting critical race theory and
critical theory in schools the stuff
they're teaching kids man is just
insane mind-blowing you should just like
the books that she
mind-blowingly insane like what do you
think indoctrination on steroids yeah
like
like worse than college campuses yes yes
it was like the same so like
the first graders no like you you
imagine like a third like a workshop a
worksheet for a third grader is going to
be like you know a train leave
cincinnati going 50 miles an hour and
then a train leaves chicago going 70
miles an hour like you know math
problems like that
we're looking at this workbook and it's
like what makes you uncomfortable in
your black skin
what like asking a child that and then
having them write down
but the thing is it's a loaded question
there was like one of the questions
no joke was something like why do you
think black people are uncomfortable in
their skin
that was like one of the questions
frankie and i was like
what but you see how the question's
loaded like it's asserting it as true
yeah yeah yeah and so the kid has to
believe that it's asking you why you
think it's true
yeah right right asserting it is true
and there was one that was like how can
you be a better uh
what did it say gender race uh right
what is gender race
race or racial justice it's just it's
just psychobabble oh dude if that's the
case then yeah
obviously i went to school in the 90s
right so like back then you know you
were still you know coloring in in
circles and stuff like oh don't mess
outside the line and you know playing
tic-tac-toe and you know maybe
you know getting some fights in the
schoolyard whatever it is but like now
if that stuff's going on that's a clown
world bro
yeah yeah i did not realize that the
school system has changed that much
that's why
that's why i asked a question do we do
we didn't want to have kids in
this current climate i i mean honestly
home school is the only way i would
actually do it
that's the only way i would i would do
it honestly home school man for sure but
the negative to that is that like you
kind of want them to be around other
kids too
yeah like that's that's i think one of
the beauties of like sending your kids
to public school is like
they build a friend group they learn how
to interact with other people they learn
like what's socially acceptable what
isn't you know
i think bullying is good personally like
but like i grew up i got bullied as a
kid and it made me a better man you know
i like it
it like kind of it reinfo if you're a
weirdo or whatever like you get picked
on for but then you would know man maybe
i shouldn't act like this or whatever it
kind of
some people make some some people break
some right but you know it lets you know
just bring your kids to the skate park
you can do that too and there's a bunch
of other kids get them involved in
sports yeah get them involved in sports
bring them out in to public spaces
community events playing instruments
these
the problem with these schools is you
don't actually know what they're
teaching your kids and you you can't
just give that responsibility to
strangers yeah and that was
that was a mistake people you know
parents made for a long time because
even
you know even outside of the
indoctrination of weird cult ideologies
and like racist garbage college campuses
are awful right now
yeah dude we hear stories about like a
dad who's like i sent my 18 year old
daughter to college she came back hating
me and her hair was her head was shaved
she was wearing weird clothes and her
face was all pierced up you're toxically
masculine dad
you know yeah yeah it's crazy man it's a
clown world but
um yeah with kids i mean if it's like
that let me
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you